you've been to the Center of the Earth
you kind of with our pressure waves yes
for every earthquake
once you find the epicenter as long as
you have earthquake sensors scattered
around the world you can time how long
it takes that signal to reach you
um
so doing you can infer the interior
structure of the Earth because different
materials will transmit those waves at
different rates than other materials
right it's a very complex map that you
make from all of these signals when
they're done wow so you add up all these
data and you can reconstruct what the
entire structure of the Earth would be
like without ever having gone there
that's amazing